I thank you very much so first of all
I'd like to thank the organizers for
putting together this very nice workshop
you know with a great collection of
people and to keep in same with the
workshop what I'm going to talk about is
some work that we have been recently
doing that combines insight from you
know all three you know database
theoretical computer science and machine
learning communities and you know and I
would love to hear your thoughts on this
so what I'm going to be talking about is
not exactly differential privacy it's
about a slightly different class of
privacy problems where differential
privacy is not quite the right fit for
these right and it'll become clear you
know why that happens in just a little
bit and I'll tell you about some work
that we have been doing in that space
over the last year or so okay so you
know as you know how can all helpfully
introduced you know these problems for
me so you know we have a lot of
sensitive data and you know what we want
to do is we want to make inferences
based on this these datasets right and
we want to preserve the privacy of
individuals in this data so in this talk
what we are going to do is we are going
to tackle the question of how do we
analyze sensitive data while still
preserving privacy okay so this is you
know kind of the same of the stock and
our focus will be on correlated data
right so what do I mean by correlated
data let me start with a couple of
examples so one example would be if you
have you know a social network and you
have information from people in the
social network who are connected
together and their attributes are very
correlated and I believe lisa has done
you know some privacy work in this
particular context so this with the and
she has shown that it's very hard to
preserve you know to stop an adversary
from inferring stuff about you in this
context right another example would be
physical activity monitoring so here
what is happening is you have a single
user and you have a lot of you know
information of what this user did across
time and now you would like to you know
publish some sort of aggregate in
mission but you want to guarantee some
measure of privacy right like you can't
hide everything about the user but
probably what you can try to hide is
what the user was doing at a specific
time point while publishing you know how
much he walks and let's say a week right
so these kinds of deals with the
correlation the correlation here is that
the activities are highly correlated
cross type so what I'm doing right now
is highly correlated with what I was
doing five minutes later right so why is
privacy hard for correlated data so I
will get into this in a little bit but
generally this is you know the one
sentence to remember right so the one
sentence remember is because neighbors
if you have a bunch of variables that
are correlated if you infer something
about one then that's a leak information
about something about the other one
about the next one so something let's go
related with you right so this is kind
of the basic underlying reason and now
people look into you know more specifics
in a little bit okay so you know how do
we define privacy we are going to talk
about how to define privacy for
correlated data first let's start out
with privacy for uncorrelated data okay
and you know so for uncorrelated data so
we are going to start out with
differential privacy and you know Kunal
already defined this but I want to
highlight one specific aspect of the
definition and then we will see how in
when we are dealing with you know these
kinds of applications I talked about
this specific aspect is you know doesn't
quite right so here remember in
differential privacy what we wanted to
guarantee was that the participation of
an individual does not change the
outcome right so for example you know if
you have some if you have an adversity
who has some prior knowledge and they
use the output of the algorithm on some
data including Alice's data to draw draw
some conclusion about Alice well they
could have done the same thing if Alice
was not on this dataset and Bob was in
the data set instead okay so this is a
differential privacy and there are a
couple things to note so one is that the
algorithm could still draw a lot of
person and conclusions about alleys
right but the point here is that alice
is the person who has the agency to
participate or not right
Alice could say that look the sound of
them you know I mean the Alice could say
that look this risk is too much for me I
decide not to participate in the
database and this is you know completely
Alice's decision right so this analysis
agency she can decide to participate in
the database or not okay so one of the
things to note here is you know
conclusions harmful conclusions here are
being drawn about Alice and Alice has
the agency to participate or not okay
now what happens with correlated data so
here is the activity monitoring example
here our job is to share some aggregate
data on the physical activity and you
know so this is you know in a slightly
more limited setting so I'm not hoping
to put this up on the internet but I'm
hoping to let's say maybe show this to
my doctor or you know nurses and so on
and what I want to do is I want to hide
the activity at a specific time right
here the agency is at the individual
level level I have the agency to
participate or not right it's not that
what I do at time T has the agency to
participate right so I have the agency
but that I want this to happen so this
assumption that you know I don't want
harmful conclusions to be drawn about
Alice analysis agency to participate
that that particular assumption doesn't
make a whole right that particular
condition doesn't really hope ok yes
question
yes yes women will come to that in just
a little bit okay so so this is so
something that is going on here another
example which I won't go into in a lot
of detail so the first example actually
you know this so the physical activity
monitoring example is kind of the one to
keep in mind throughout this talk and
this example kind of arose when one of
my colleagues who works on embedded
systems you know came to me and said
look you know we have all this data and
you know we kind of want to share them
with researchers and you know we don't
know what to do there's something you
know can you do something and you say
something about its privacy so that's
how I got interested in this problem so
here is another example which is you
know also which we will also be able to
say a little bit about is let's say what
you are doing is you have a set of
schools and the schools have and you
know there's a survey and the schools
have the agency to participate in a
survey which says you know and which
which is a survey about let's say how
many people have fuel in the school
right and here what they would do at the
end of the survey is public AG publish
aggregate statistics over a set of
schools but what you would like to do is
to prevent an adversary from knowing who
has flu right here the agency is at the
school level right so the school makes a
decision to participate or not but the
individual students in the school may
feel like they don't want their privacy
to be violated right so again this
period of agency versus unit of
information hiding is different right so
this is a slightly different setting
okay so what happens when you use
differential privacy for correlated so
here are so let's let's look at the
activity monitoring example closely
right so here our goal is to publish to
activity histogram over a reasonably
long period of time right let's say
maybe some beeps or something right and
you want adverse I want to prevent
adversity from knowing what the person
was doing at each time T okay here you
don't remember agency is at you know the
individual level not at time entry level
okay okay so what happens if you use P
or differential privacy what would
happen is notice this is one person
right so pure differential privacy you
would just add it of noise to hide one
person's data and it's not going to be
exactly the right thing to do right so
David would be too much nice
another option is because you were just
you know this is one person and you are
hoping to hide you know all about one
person right so you know the imagine one
so generally I guess so what the it is
the kind of thing that Kunal was trying
to get at is the reason so what
differential privacy is doing is if you
have advocates over many people then you
blood the contribution of one person and
you know and that preserves aggregate
over many people but no no I know I'm
just going over some yes I agree with
you I'm going over some base cases so
let's let's make them this is that how
you I don't see the reasoning go back I
don't sit what's the reasoning for too
much noise well the too much noise is
here this is just one person's data
right so you would add enough noise to
mask a single person's data so it does
it like getting differential privacy for
one person yeah exactly
from one with zero people yeah it can't
have any utility so the next one would
be entry differential privacy so here
you can say that the participation
across you know over entries of a say
sorry if the participation of a single
entry will not make a difference here
what you would do is it would output a
histogram of activities and you would
add noise its standard deviation one
right so this is you know this is maybe
a solution but here what would happen is
it would not prevent the adversary from
inferring what you were doing because
activities across time are correlated
right and notice so in differential
privacy when we had a lot of database
endeavor a lot of people who were
correlated there we would say okay fine
but this is not my secret right so we
would say that okay but I have the
agency but here that is not true right
there
no individual would have the agency and
they would say i-15 to submit and you
know that's okay right here that
wouldn't quite be the case it is a
different setting I apologize I'm
actually still stuck on Russia's
question I'm having trouble
understanding this Shay's also stuck
with Lucia's question okay so why don't
we come back to this after at the end of
the top right so this is they don't the
relatively basic I can you know I can
work on some calculations so you guys at
the end of the term so then the other
option is you know entry group DP right
here what is happening is all the
entries are correlated right so here I
again you know you would add noise with
standard deviation t and that would
again be too much noise and so you know
so now you know the question is you know
how can we yes that is true
let me finish let me finish the stock
market okay so what we are hoping to
exploit out of this is you know it is
sure that all the entries are correlated
but you know so then you can say okay so
what do you expect again so what you do
expect you gain over here is that even
though everything is technically
correlated the average amount of
correlation is not that high
right and this is exactly what we will
exploit what will exploit it is that you
know if you look at time entry one your
correlation with time entries that are
really far away is really low right so
that is what a why we expect to do
anything in this case right and that is
why we expect to get again and that is
exactly what we do okay
so how do we define privacy in these
cases so we are going to use puffer fish
privacy which was you know which was
some very beautiful work which came out
of the database community by you know
and this was proposed by Kiefer and much
in our chili in 2012 let me talk about
the definition right so in pufferfish
you have three you know so you have
there are three parts components to the
definition so the first is a set of
Secrets right so a set of Secrets which
reflects the information that is to be
protected right so an example would be
you may want to protect Alice
ages 25 or bob has a disease right so
the point I want to make here is here
this information might be more
fine-grained or more coarse screen right
so you may not care if I get to know
that Alice's ages you know with Alice's
like a minor or not but I don't you know
Silas doesn't want to be known you know
it's okay if you know that Alice is not
a minor right however it's not okay but
you know it but you want to maybe
protect the age within a certain small
range right so that is permissible right
the other thing is you know you may want
to protect specific features Bob has a
disease or not okay so that is the
secret set you also have pairs of
secrets so you know here again a pair of
secret could be Alice doesn't want it to
be known whether she's in her 20s and or
in her 40s but maybe it's okay to know
that Alice's let's say below retirement
age okay another one would be maybe you
know an example would be you know Bob is
in the data set or Bob is not in the
data set maybe you don't want that
bursary to be able to tell ya finally
what we have is a distribution class
theta and this is it is this
distribution class that will be used to
model the correlation in the data okay
so here I what is happening so how do
you have this distribution what would be
an example of this distribution class
one example would be maybe you have this
connection graph G and then you have
some you know some probabilities so you
can say so maybe the disease transmits
with a certain range of probabilities
and this is the connection graph right
early transmit with this probability
another one would be so this is the kind
of thing that we would be using in the
physical activity monitoring example so
you have a Markov chain whose transition
matrix lies in some set of transition
matrices right so this would be another
example and this is this patter that is
used to model the correlation in the
data right so the way to kind of think
about theta is theta reflects the
adversaries belief about something that
might even about but it right so it
reflects that versus belief about the
data
and this is how you how you define
puffer fish you say that an algorithm is
Epsilon puffer fish private with
parameters sq and petaa if for all
there's Esiason q for all theta and
theta X you know drawn from a
distribution theta the the likelihood
that a of X is equal to T conditioned on
si and theta is at most e to the epsilon
times the likelihood that a of X is
equal to te conditioned on SJ + theta
right and the weight is differs from
differential privacy is you know there
is the presence of this theta right and
this probability is with respect to the
randomness and algorithm as well as this
pattern okay as well as this
distribution theta so so the secret
pairs are you know you can just design
them you can build them into your
algorithm so you know they could be
Alice's age is 25 verses Alice's 8 is 26
so these could be secret pairs and they
would you know they would you know some
this is a very much a mega framework and
they would very much depend on your
application I will talk about the
capital as you use capital S so capital
S is your si SJ is the Q is a subset of
s crosses later anywhere else in the
definition yeah well whether that's what
happened to us there is no so here is a
subset of s crosses that's all so it's
kind of a no yes oh I agree it doesn't
appear in the definition it's it's
useful for introducing Q I guess
to protect the secret right so where is
the stick of chalk in the definition
over here yeah so you have pairs of
Secrets that you don't want that versity
to be able to distinguish between so
this is kind of like you know pronounce
red ones and blue ones secrets
I believe everywhere the letter S yes to
me like I still get the perfectly good
definition yeah this is fine yeah yeah
anything if you can delete something it
you don't change the meaning delete it I
agree with you yes I mean isn't this is
the secret set s is just an artifact or
making it just more understandable q is
a subset of s process so it's just yeah
I agree with you yes the definition
could be written without yeah okay and
so you know if you think of kunas red
and blue also think of this as the red
world and think of that as the blue
world and the red world is restricted
eyeholes and blue world is my secret
jayhawks right so this is kind of like
that and so in fact what they showed was
that it generalizes differential privacy
these are looking at slightly different
frameworks but you know yeah slightly
different I I would say kind of
philosophies but anyway so realize the
differential privacy in fact you can
show that buffer you know differential
privacy is equivalent to a form of
puffer fish when these things hold so
when your secrets are of the form person
I has value a for all I all a in domain
X right and your pairs of secrets are of
the pairs of the form person I has value
a versus person I has value B right and
theta is the set of all distributions
where each person I is drawn
independently
and then the other question is you know
what happens when that is all possible
distributions well you can show that no
utility is possible other than cheese so
this is you know something that you know
which also agrees with what Kunal were
saying earlier about you know if you can
make any then there would be no it will
be possible right any prior not you know
any kind of connection and these things
are allowed then okay so now you know we
have defined this you know define
pufferfish question is how do we design
a mechanism for this and you know there
were several special case mechanisms
before our work including some you know
very recent work and some punker and
work with us and the question is can we
define a completely general mechanism
you know which is analogous to I guess
in a canal called it a Laplace mechanism
right so we had two sensitivity
mechanism where you look at a function
you look at this global sensitivity and
you add noise proportional to it
question is can we you know can we get
something like that for pufferfish and
what we show is that there is something
like this so we do define an analog to
sensitivity and that is so this is what
we call the Wasserstein mechanism okay
so what is the vasa so what is what is
the intuition so you know in the
sensitivity mechanism what we would be
doing is we would look at two data sets
D and E prime which differ in one
person's value and we would find the
worst-case distance between them okay
in our case we don't really have two
data sets what we have are these two
distributions right so the probability
of you know the function that we are
trying to estimate the distribution of
the function that we are trying to
estimate condition on si and settl
versus the distribution that we are
trying of the function condition on SJ
and set R right and now you know so now
we have these two distributions what
what is really the relevant distance
okay and as it happens if you write this
down you write down the definition and
stare at it long enough what happens is
the relevant distance turns out to be
what is called the infinitive or system
distance so this is I guess a lot of you
has probably heard about the earth mover
distance so the earth mover would be l1
versus teen and this is the infinity
version of it so what is the infinity
versus to understand
suppose you are given two measures P and
Q and G PQ is the set of all joint
distributions which has P and Q as
marginals right so the Infinity was a
certain distance is going to be the
infimum over gamma in this set right
let's say maximum X pairs x and y over
the support of gamma the distance
between x and y right so let's say you
have a metric so what you're trying to
do is you are trying to look at the best
you know so you're trying to look at the
best coupling and the maximum distance
that you move any probability mass due
to that couple right and that is your
infinite evil system distance right so
just to give you a pictorial
representation suppose this is your P
and that is your Q right and you're
trying to move some probability mass
from P to Q okay
and so maybe one no so the you know so
you want to move some mass from P Tokyo
and you want to constrain the maximum
distance moved by any probability mass
to be as small as possible
and you know that small you know that
objective value is your infinitive or
system distance okay so you move 0 from
here to here this moved by 0 right
because it hasn't really moved any
distance right and now you take your 1
you know you move it up to here so this
is 1 and you move the one thing over
here but you have a probability mass at
K and you have to move that to and that
you know the best the you can do with
that is you can move it to K minus by a
distance of K minus 1 right and in this
case of the BJ - yes you use gamma
somewhere in the distance maybe
multiplies that with gamma of XY I don't
know
so in this case no that's a good
question so here you don't there are
some cases where we can show that this
is tight and this is I mean I so my
intuition is that this is partly because
you know the differential private you
know this these kinds of definitions you
are just looking at the worst-case ratio
so some cases we can show that is tight
over your right so if this was kind of
an average
definition you would need to weigh by
gamma but in this case it's not always
tight but there are some cases where
this is tight so this is so in this case
the infinity vs. in distance would be K
minus 1 and here is the vs. in mechanism
you look at your function that you're
trying to approximate you have your
puffer fish framework and data for each
sis chain Q theta and theta you define
these two you know so these are
essentially the distributions of the
functions conditioned on Si and SJ you
calculate the vs. teen the infinity was
a sin distance between them you find the
maximum of these over IJ and cetera and
then that is you know an analogue to
your global sensitivity and then you add
noise proportional to W star that is the
W star is in an elliptical burn
sensitivity and then you add noise
proportional to W star over Epsilon
okay so this is the that is that was
used in mechanism okay so now you know
there are good properties it's epsilon
private it reduces to sensitivity in it
this also reduces to sensitivity
mechanism by the way when you are
looking at differential privacy okay the
question the problem is that
computational efficiency right so you
know we have to do a lot of work and you
know and the question is can we do any
better and what I will show is for some
specific cases of correlation that
includes our chain example we are
actually able to do much better yeah so
so what kind of correlation across theta
we are looking at well we will be
looking at Bayesian networks so what is
a Bayesian network so this is you know
these are very commonly used in machine
learning each node is a variable and
they're all connected into a directed
acyclic graph okay and a joint
distribution across variables is
probability of x1 to xn is product over
I probability of X I'll conditioned on
the parents of X I right and this is you
know you know Markov chains a lot of
other things fall into this and this is
very commonly used in various
so so let me start so what can be hope
to exploit here so let me start out with
a simple example let's say we have a
Markov chain where each X I could be 0
or 1 and we have these state transition
probabilities so you stay in the same
state with probability 0 move to a
different state bit probably it's a good
probability P you move to a different
state with probability 1 minus P now
let's say they're trying to hide X 1 if
you look at what happens in X 2 extra
was actually quite correlated with X 1
right so if the next one is 0
probability that X 2 is 0 is P when X 1
is 1 that is 1 minus P however if you
look at X I where I is you know a
distance I away then the probability
that X I is zero conditioned on X 1 is 0
is 1/2 plus 1/2 times twice P minus 1 to
the I minus 1 right and if P is not 0 or
1 this is actually really quite small
right and what this means is as if grow
fur go for the walk further and further
away from X 1 your influence is really
diminishing with that right and this is
kind of what we are hoping to exploit
and this is this is what people okay so
suppose what we so here's the main idea
for algorithm suppose we want to protect
X 1 we have some nodes that are local to
X 1 which have high correlation and then
we have the remaining nodes that are
almost independent right what we are
going to do is we are going to hire add
a lot of noise that will hide the effect
of the local nodes and then we'll add a
small collection term that will account
for the rest which are almost
independent ok ok so I talked about
almost independence how do we define
independence as it happens that in this
case if you do some calculations the
measure of Independence that becomes
relevant is what we call the max
influence okay so what is the Max
entrance the max influence of a node X I
on a set of nodes X I is the following
this is the maximum over a and B where X
I you know a and B are the values at X I
can take write X I takes values a versus
X I takes values B so premium overall
site are in your distribution class
maximum of a little X our probability
our takes the value little X our
condition on X equal to a over a & peeta
over the probability that X our takes
value X are conditioned on excitement to
be a theta right and if these two were
you know if XR was independent of X I
this would be zero right because this
ratio would be one and the log will take
you to zero it's been it's close to zero
that means it's sort of you know it's
close to being independent and as it
happens if you do that calculation you
know the kind of correction term that we
would need for this sort of thing would
be of the order of you know of the form
of e to the maxim okay so fine so now we
know how to measure independence but the
question is you know you have this you
know you have this graphical model how
do you find large independent sets right
and in general root for search is
expensive and what we will do is we will
talk about a way in which we can use
some of the structural properties of the
Bayesian network itself okay so what is
the structural property I would start
let me start with a basic definition
that you know I guess the graphical so
there is this notion or what is called a
Markov blanket so what is the mark of
blanket the Markov blanket of a node X I
is the set of nodes XS such that X I is
independent of the rest of the graph
conditioned on X s okay and this is you
know so this is the minimal set of nodes
right so and usually this is the not you
should in general this is the parents
and the children and the other parents
of the shipment okay so this is you know
it's called the Markov blanket for our
purposes we need something a little bit
different a little bit more general so
we define the notion of a Markov quilt
which is more general Markov blanket so
what is a mark of quilt X Q is a mark of
quilt for X i if you delete X Q then
that will break up the graph into xn and
X are right and XII is in XL and XR is
independent of X i given X Q okay so
here what is going on is X Q is kind of
the boundary xn is like a neighborhood
that's surrounding a
sigh and XR is the rest of the graph
okay and what we want is X is
independent of X I conditioned on X cube
okay so if you to see how this is a
generalization of Markov blanket in
Markov blanket you know is a mark of
wealth but xn is simply excited right
and now what we are doing is we are
allowing a larger set of nodes xn right
so that is just the that is exactly how
we are generalizing this okay so we are
allowing a larger set of neighborhood
nodes and why we need that will become
clear very soon okay so you know okay
that is all very well how does this
relate to our algorithm well remember
what we were hoping to do is we were
hoping to have some local nodes which
will have high correlation and then have
some you know almost independent nodes
and then we will we were hoping to add
some correction term for them okay now
what will happen is xn will be our local
nodes given the mark of current and XQ
Union XR will be the remaining and you
know we don't really need to worry about
XR because condition on X Q X is
independent so we don't need to you know
when we do this you know when we test
for max inference we only really need to
look at X cube we don't really need to
look at X I because condition the next
and now you know the question is how do
we find a good mark of print well what
we can do is we can search over mark of
quail's of the graph to find one which
needs the optimal amount of noise and
you know we don't need to really search
over all mark of Wales if we could
search over all mark of Wales we will
find the most optimum one but if you
have a set of really plausible mark of
quills which is a smaller set then you
know we could search over them and you
know that would give us more
computational efficiency and you know as
we will see in some cases that is
helpful and so how do we go from these
mark of quills to the amount of noise so
as it happens if you are using mark of
killed XQ then the amount of noise that
you need to add sort of looks like this
right on the numerator you have the
cardinality of X n so as xn grows larger
the amount of noise grows larger but as
xn grows larger your XQ also gets
further
so it's Max and Friends goes down and
this correction factor will go down
right so in the denominator you have
epsilon minus this max influence which
is kind of the correction factor which
will you know go down okay and you need
to balance these two effects right so as
your as you get further and further your
X n gets larger this gets smaller and as
you get closer your X and get smaller
but this gets larger right so what you
need to do is you make sure you balance
these two effects when you choose your
mark of quit so then this is essentially
the mark of pull mechanism for each X I
you find the mark of quail X cube for
XIV the minimum which has called si and
then you know you maximize over each X I
because you need to protect each of
these okay and advantage so this will
preserve epsilon pufferfish privacy we
can show that advantages is that it's
poly time in special cases okay
now coming back to our example on
physical activity monitoring remember we
had this you know we have this Markov
chain here what happens is that the
minimum mark of quills are of really
simple forms right if you are looking to
protect a node X I Markov polls have the
form X I minus ax I plus B the minimum
Marco quills had this really nice form
so this makes the search very easy right
so it's efficiently searchable you know
it so there are not that many things to
search over and in this case as it
happens we can do even further do more
things we can clean things up even more
so if P theta is the set of transition
matrices describing its theta then under
some assumptions essentially you know
via sargodha city-style assumptions the
two relevant parameters are one is the
is pi sub theta which is the minimum
probability of X under the stationary
distribution that the minimum is over
any petaa in your class and then G theta
is the minimum eigen gap right so if if
you have a class of class theta of your
transition matrices all you need to know
are these two parameters you don't need
to check for every set of one-by-one
which can help efficiency quite a lot
and in this case you can even write down
not exactly the max and friends but an
upper bound on the Maximus in closed
form right which makes life much much
much more simpler okay and so here is
the algorithm and you know if you run it
naively the runtime will be T cube and
you know with some optimizations you can
bring it down to T Square by T is the
length of the chain and you know
obviously this is going to be
statistically consistent and then one
more thing that we can show here is that
it also composes so remember you know
the kunal talked about if you use the
same data set many times then the
privacy budget goes down gracefully
right in general and pufferfish that is
not true but for this particular
mechanism we can show that this is true
so this will compose okay and this is
true and I believe it's partly because
we are doing you know some sort of group
DP over the local nodes plus a
correction factors I think that's
probably that's my intuition why it's
the case okay so let's look at little
remaining five minutes I have so let's
maybe look at some simulations and
experiments so you know so first we look
at you know a very simple 1d simulation
you have a Markov chain with you know
state zero and one and there are these
two parameters right so P is you go from
zero to zero and Q is you go from one to
zero and we are looking at a model as
theta so theta enough to describe each
model you need two numbers and what we
will do is we will say that these
numbers lie in some interval so the
modern classes are an interval the
numbers live in this interval and just
to you know just so that I don't have to
do 3d figures I will make the interval
symmetric right so I'll say we are
looking at intervals of the form L to 1
minus L okay and we are looking at
sequences of length hundred and here is
what we get
so mark of 12 mechanism is our stuff and
this in financial privacy is this other
concurrent word due to quotient
Kleinberg and you know this these are
some results so what we what you see
here in the x-axis you see L right so L
measures you know if L is small
means you were looking over a wider
model class and you know you expect this
to happen so if you are looking over a
wider or trying to guarantee privacy
over a lot of more adversaries then you
know obviously your performance will get
worse so you expect this to happen and
on the y-axis you have normalized error
so what we see so this gray line
so this JK is 16 their algorithm will
work only under certain conditions on
the parameters of theta right and the
gray line is where this condition is so
to the left of the gray line their
algorithm doesn't work to the right of
the gray line it does work ok and what
we see is as we get closer to L equal to
0.5 so L equal to 0.5 is when things are
independent so the states are all
independence as we get closer to L equal
to 0.5 their algorithm does better and
better and you know it will very close
to L equal to 0.5 it will do better than
our algorithm but our algorithm works
for a broader range of parameters and
you know kind of in this region between
this gray line and this area our
algorithm will work better so it's a
mixed bag if your algorithm you know if
your theta is really close to 0.5 then
you know they will do better for a
broader range of parameters you know B
we are all our algorithm will work and
you know for some range of parameters
we'll do better yes point 5 you can also
compare with entry different shell
privacy
so finally this is some very preliminary
experiments on on real data so this is a
dataset that we got from our medical
school on so they have some data on
physical activity performed by an
overweight subject and what they are
hoping to do is they're going to hoping
to kind of aggregate this data and based
on the aggregate data they may want to
give recommendations to subjects and you
know build apps and stuff like that
right and here what we did was you know
again we looked at this histogram so
there are basically four four states so
walking or running standing still
standing and then moving and sedentary
and if you run the mark of quilt
mechanism what we found was that the
Elven error was point zero one two group
D P obviously you can't really expect it
to do very well because it's the entire
Markov chain is you know and there you
get 0.214 and what before was the G K 16
in this case doesn't apply because if
you look at the transition matrix that
you get from the Markov chain those
parameters they actually lie on the
other side of the gray line so we found
this for this data set similarly here's
another one we looked at some
electricity consumption of a single
household in Vancouver so we looked at
the electricity consumption and then we
discretized it to a whole bunch of
levels right and this is the histogram
again your Markov pull mechanism is you
know giving you decent results I think
this one is for epsilon equal to one the
previous one probably was a large
eruption I think the previous one was
epsilon equal to five so here Markov
will mechanism is giving these and
results but GK 16 also doesn't apply
because again the theta falls on the
other side of the gray line okay so in
conclusion we have talked about you know
privacy of correlated data we have even
two new mechanisms looked at you know
this mark of quick mechanism we have
kind of worked with it a bit more
established some composition properties
future work is you know how can you get
more efficient mechanisms more detailed
composition properties you know maybe I
even more problems that fall in this
area and look at what kinda models are
interesting for them and so on and
finally I will stop with you know
thanking my co-authors so Shuang is my
student she's the one who did a lot of
work on this paper ijen is also my
student and money is my colleague from
UCLA who's the one who proposed this
problem to me in the first place so he
said oh we have this problem with all
this data you do privacy can you say
something about this thank you so you
say that if our adversary's belief lies
in this model then they can't yeah that
is absolutely true
do you know of any queries and ways
annoys it up that are robust to okay so
that's an excellent question so for if
you have all this revisions better then
you can't you know gave me guarantee and
utility however what we can show so we
have this data right what we can show is
if there is a slight model mismatch
right so it versus belief doesn't really
fall in petaa but it falls in something
close to theta then you know we can
guarantee epsilon plus some measure of
that closeness right and the measure is
actually not kill divergence but it's a
you know it's off the order of its
basically max some measure of max
divergence so you know how in statistics
we have this theorem for like he would
based inference that if you have model
mismatch then what you are getting is
something you know the back heel
divergence is the gap here it is max
because of the nature of privacy
so I actually have a question - so your
argument goal is to try to commercialize
been ejected now if I don't know
anything about data I think actually
currently over there and these solutions
and the combination of how much noise I
want to have we could you can touch them
okay this is how much is actually a
fascinating way of putting this so yeah
but that's so that's a very interesting
point yeah yeah you're absolutely right
that's that's a very nice way of putting
it there
absolutely okay so I think everybody's
hungry